welcome to this video playing FM Kineo
from the US playing a Slav let's see how
he's playing the exchange I think I
played him just recently and forgot
about that yeah well I played the
exchange myself so cannot be too harsh
about that like well what a boring
player I'll play this myself okay I've
tried to instill a bit of a fight into
this look you won now that's not so
ambitious okay let's see and if I try to
manage to unbalance the position Bishop
g3m I'm taking and gain the bishop pal
at least it's something
yes this is a possible a possible way to
play and now it's interesting but I can
um you know I can't even consider to
take on h4 but there that's not good
okay um this is the standard way to play
and I'm going for that I mean standards
in general terms I don't really know
that if this is a precise a precisely
known theoretical position but in other
positions um he do that night tour to
get the bishop after all why just gained
a bit of time but he has played ninety
two and this is not an optimal way to
use the time and it should be it should
be quite okay what black is trying to do
in the long run are this interesting
hmm interesting it's to play you fine
this is what I wanted to say but I was
immediately trying to calculate if I can
actually do one play a sacrifice yeah
whatever I'm 94 I was thinking Edie
Queen takes and there's Queen III as an
idea that's Queen takes d3 but is Queen
f3 and this covers everything
I will then g4 okay I think probably
Knight takes d4 isn't a good move but
well let's see what is what he's doing
now
the direct way to play take you on g5 I
think didn't didn't help I wouldn't help
uh-huh interesting
yeah probably Knight c5 his idea hmm
interesting
young soo good square for the night
yeah this is a bit risky maybe but ok
well short castles wasn't possible but
don't always need to be cautious now
baby 3 very slow play ok well let's
let's consider how to how to get ahead
here see what is he doing night a for to
see five on
I play Knight a five-night c5 you know I
can't take one B - okay well let's see
if he exchanges the Knights I should be
okay with no Knight coming to see five
of them surprising okay I keep it simple
player five block the center intention
g4 h 5 h 4 very simple chess and I'm not
sure what he's doing in the meantime we
can play Queen b3 maybe try to exchange
something on b5 but we can prepare
before maybe you should prepare before
and five really wants to prepare g fo g
4 h 5 and so on
I'm not behind on the clock that's good
news
try to play play play
quickly now ah interesting nice plays
preparing before there's this this or
this manner but I can't play Queen b6
that's not not the end of the world okay
let's let's have a look at this pawn
before maybe and I can I can second the
phone some point
yeah well h4 of course still an idea the
SEC doesn't really lead to anything I
can you can take now it it gets more
interesting the potential pawn sacrifice
p sacrifice with the c3 Knight being
loose yeah interesting Bishop a4 I'm not
I'm not sure if this is helpful
I don't really I don't I don't really
have anything on the seafoam
hmm
okay I know it looks completely
illogical but I just want to try to to
to be more ambitious here check they
didn't want to just trade everything on
the seafoam
and now queen d8 and maybe I can
innovate on the h-file quindi a drug
takes h1 look a jade twice he is
sacrificing the exchange no not
interested
rather go to the age farm if I take him
he's got the long diagonal I'm not sure
Quincy three of the dark squats are very
weak don't want to take the rook
I'd rather increase my pressure on the
edge file make him think about if I
might captured later
hmm yeah I thought this was the threat
really Queen each wife has a big threat
is some more not reacting to it at all
in our gauge to look like resigned looks
like a disaster
yeah the sim was a position that really
AM yeah the problem is white does not
really have an active plan he only can
can stay passive and defend and this is
this position I mean he probably should
have enough defensive resources but it's
not fun to play it alone yeah this
didn't didn't didn't really help but
check yeah just uncomfortable just very
uncomfortable I have to straight forward
plan with the h-bomb and what are you
doing against it can't difficult to
defend around here it's probably it's
probably gone computer wants to take on
c5 but I'm not convinced this is simple
and good I'm just going for the edge fun
and win the game this rook is just not
doing anything here don't need to take
it the whole line here this is
interesting for for black players
wanting to unbalance rupee one is a bit
bit passive I think but should be fine
with them that is normally palladium but
I'm not not 100% sure this is mostly
done by black to to get some some
conflict in this in the game this Bishop
is not great of course with the pawn on
e6 but if you get the bishop app you can
do something in the long run alright
thanks for watching